a living building is really a building
that is a positive contributor to its
broader ecology throughout every stage
of its life so conventional buildings
are responsible for about 37% of global
greenhouse gas emissions and given the
fact that we spend about 90% of our time
in them they tend to offgas a ton of
harmful chemicals into our indoor air
and also contribute to a growing
pollution and waste problem a living
building takes responsibility and
account for everything that comes into
its DNA and all of the effluence that
flow out into its environment it's
really exciting to have the living
Village here on campus at Yale because
it opens up an opportunity for us to get
to understand and learn about our local
climate our Flora our fauna and in doing
so engage and prototype new ways of
living
together
[Music]
oh